[Musique]
c'est sur le termac de l'aéroport Roland
Garos que le premier
b7878 s'est posé après un périple qu'il
l' mené de Seattle en passant par Paris
vers la réunion les élus réunionnés qui
avaient fait le déplacement étaient très
fiers de présenter ce nouvel avion
Dreamliner le premier à voler sous
immatriculation
Française exprimer tant ma fierté
personnelle celle également du conseil
départemental des élus que je représente
ici et plus largement la fierté
réunionnaise nous avons eu cette fierté
de se dire que sur le territoire le plus
excentré de la France métropolitaine
c'est la compagnie régionale de australe
porté par la Région Réunion et nous-même
via la Sematra qui au nom de la France
achète ses Boeing 787 oui nous sommes
fiers parce que nous visons le
développement de notre pays nous sommes
élus pour défendre la population et
pourter la porter l'avenir l'arrivée de
cette nouvelleion d'abord c'est une
fierté pour la Réunion c'est une fierté
pour notre île c'est le premier avion
dmeliner de nouvelle génération
euh nouvelle technologie français vous
vous rendez pas compte la la réunion
peut être Fiè d'avoir
su avant tous les territoires français
avant tous les départements français
avant toutes les compagnies françaises
avoir un un avion de nouvelle
technologie et c'est vrai un challenge
que que notre compagnie régionale a
porté et que nous les élus nous ne
pouvons que nous réjouir puisque nous
accompagnons cette compagnie la
présidente du département et sa deuxème
vice-présidente ont insisté sur les
perspectives économiques que généreront
le
b7878 pour la réunion le président de
Région Didier Robert et directeur de la
cmatra pour sa part rappeler
l'importance pour la réunion de pouvoir
relier Paris dans de bonnes conditions
mais le président de région souhaite que
la compagnie aérostrale puisse rayonner
dans tout l'Océan Indien c'est un
événement pour austral c'est un
événement pour la Réunion la compagnie
aérustrale et la première compagnie
française aujourd'hui à avoir dans sa
flotte donc ces avions de nouvelle
génération le 787 il y en aura un
deuxième qui sera livré d'ici la fin de
cette année et donc nous allons de cette
manière compléter cette flotte et faire
en sorte que austral puisse assumer
pleinement ses deux principales missions
aujourd'hui celle de pouvoir assurer la
liaison entre la Réunion et Paris et
permettre à de très nombreux runonné
notamment à travers la continuité
territoriale donc de pouvoir
effectivement se dépasser le plus
simplement possible et puis la deuxième
élément le deuxième élément de la
stratégie globale c'est le pouvoir
rayonner dans l'espace Océan Indien et
faire en sorte que la réunion soit un
territoire ouvert sur le reste du monde
notamment sur l'Afrique de l'Est et sur
l'Inde et bien sûr sur la Chine demain
on a hésité entre un avion qui était un
avion d'ancienne génération on aurait pu
penser au 767 moins performant au 787
qui vraiment nous projeter dans le futur
je pense que le chix a été fait c'est te
dire ben écoutez il faut être ambitieux
fa se projeter vraiment dans le future
c'est ce qu'on a fait et je pense que
c'est une fierté pour nous austral et
pour la Réunion indubitablement cet
avion est est une perde un développement
économique qui passera plus
particulièrement par Mayotte le préfet
de la Réunion et le président du conseil
départemental de Mayotte voit dans cette
nouvelle liaison directe Mayotte Paris
un vrai levier pour le commerce et le
tourisme dans l'Î au
parfa
[Musique]